[Música]
a partir de este momento les voy a pedir
a todos que por favor cierren los ojos
soñamos
y nos trasladamos a la montaña
un día de invierno
todo blanco
listos con amigos para hacer una
esquiada
comenzamos la bajada a toda velocidad
sintiendo el viento en la cara
esa sensación de plenitud vueltas para
un lado para el otro
tirando nieve para arriba agarramos un
obstáculo lo saltamos vemos otros los
saltamos y vamos en busca de uno más
grande lo vemos lo encaramos lo saltamos
y volamos
[Música]
ahora piensen
que se les cruzaría por la cabeza
si en ese momento le sucede algo
inesperado
los invito a que se destapen todos los
ojos
yo quiero hablarles de cómo me adapté
ante una situación extrema
tuve un accidente haciendo snowboard acá
en bariloche un accidente tonto si bien
no eres un experto
y hacíamos locuras fue por una caída
normal al instante supe lo que me estaba
pasando miraba a mis piernas y no
estaban donde mi cabeza lo decía
mi primera reacción tirado en la nieve
boca arriba con mis amigos alrededor fue
chicos son de esta manera no quiero
seguir viviendo no sólo había perdido la
sensibilidad por debajo de la cintura
sino que también había perdido la
movilidad de mis piernas
me creía que era imposible continuar la
vida en silla de ruedas
al poco tiempo
en el hospital
en la cama de nuevo boca arriba abren la
puerta de la habitación y entra en mis
abuelos mi mamá mis hermanos y amigos de
la infancia
y ahí la vi
al lado mío
esperándome
los mire a ellos tome fuerzas
y les dije que me pasaran a ella
una vez sentado descubrió el suero los
puse entre mis piernas
y avance un poquito cuando avance ellos
abrieron seguí encare la puerta
y salí a recorrer los pasillos
como si estuviese feliz saludando a la
gente hola que tal ola una cinta
haciendo snowboard es como si fuese
interesante
ese fue el momento más fuerte de
aceptación que estaba atravesando
comencé mi rehabilitación con la cabeza
puesta en volver a trabajar
en esquiar
y continuar colaborando con chicos con
discapacidad como lo hacía antes del
accidente porque yo
trabajaba con personas con discapacidad
antes de quedar en silla de ruedas
al poco tiempo
me pasó algo inesperado conocí una chica
una chica muy alta
un metro 82
y saben como me decían a mí el enano y
como todo apetito me fui a buscar la más
alta es más con ella nos reíamos porque
me decía si tuviese conocido parado y
tuviese de bolilla deseo por acá
nos conocimos
nos elegimos
nos enamoramos pero pese a todos los
prejuicios de la gente y aprendimos lo
que era una pareja no convencional
llamamos la atención en todos lados alto
el otro centrado
nos casamos y tuvimos nuestra primera
hija joaquina y luego los mellizos auto
vine aquí
quienes los amo con todo el corazón como
me dicen ellos y formamos una hermosa
familia
luego
aprendí a esquiar
pero esta vez en un equipo adaptado
sentado y con el correr de los años tuve
la oportunidad
de hacer el curso de instructor de esquí
convencional qué significa eso que le
iba a dar clases a personas que caminan
obviamente se aprobaba
aprobé y no solo a proveer sino que tuve
la suerte de ser el primer instructor en
el mundo en sillas de ruedas
a su vez
tuve que enfrentar a otro cambio
se acuerdan de la chica alta que la
velas instante mi esposa la mamá de mis
hijos
me separé
y la vida me puso a prueba nuevamente
pero esta vez como padre
no se dan no se imaginan el temor que
tenía de no poder hacerme cargo de la
crianza de mis hijos
por dentro yo decía
con actitud y esfuerzo lo voy a lograr
si lo tengo que hacer bien claro eran
muy chiquitos tenían tres años los
mellizos
y joaquín a 6 años
lo que antes hacíamos dados ahora lo
tenía que enfrentar solo
y es así como tuve todas las ocupaciones
de cualquier padre cocinarles bañarlos
cambiarlos
que hagan las tareas preparar la vienda
para el otro día que se acuestan
temprano
despertarlos tarea difícil
que se preparen
y ayudándolos a prepararse y sobre todas
las cosas que lleguemos horario
una vez que los tengo a los tres
sentados en el auto con el cinturón de
seguridad puesto
cargo mi silla
miro la hora y no se dan una idea cómo
festejó lo que me creía que era
imposible vamos vamos vamos chico vamos
que llegamos horario si ellos también se
ríen
también me pasa que subimos al auto
estamos preparados para salir y cuando
voy a aplaudir me dicen me olvidé la
mochila
quiero ir al baño
pues bajamos todos
subo al auto después de que hicieron
todo subo al auto me dicen para pino
pero disque voy a aplaudir a la hora que
estamos llegando
también me pongo triste me angustio
tengo mi momento de felicidad de alegría
mis preocupaciones como a todos les pasa
y busco la forma de despejar me
desahogarme de descargarme
en invierno es que en verano corto el
pasto en mi casa
si me preguntan cómo tomo o entiendo lo
que me pasó yo le respondo que me pasó
algo inesperado y que a partir de ahí
empecé a valorar todas las cosas que me
suceden
y les aseguro
que soy muy feliz tengo una hermosa
calidad de vida hago lo que me gusta
que me gustaría destacar de lo que pasó
que a todos ustedes a todos
les ocurre en cambio a lo largo de la
vida
y que pudiendo atravesar y superar los
procesos lógicos de adaptación les
aseguro que se puede seguir adelante
porque no se trata de sobrevivir
sino de aceptar lo que aún no le toca
proyectándose a una buena vida
y poniéndose nuevos objetivos
de qué depende eso
de la actitud que le pongamos frente a
las cosas
de reacomodar expectativas
de poner nuevos objetivos
a mí
aceptar la nueva realidad
y reacomodar mis expectativas
me cambió la vida
adaptarme al cambio
me salvó la vida
lo que quiero transmitirles
es que no pongamos el foco en el hecho
sino en la actitud y el esfuerzo que
debemos lograr para atravesar esos
procesos
ahora busco nuevos objetivos nuevas
cosas por aprender por experimentar por
explorar por dar
porque yo sé que no voy a volver a
patear una pelota pero sí sé
que voy a seguir sintiendo el viento en
la cara muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]